I'm getting your shower falling on it's
not an alien invasion movie without
hearing a cacophony of reporters at the
beginning of it I have one frame is
clear the world war oh good then we can
dust off our grainy battle stock footage
all breaches while long - coastline the
worst part about this alien attack is
all those Nebraskans sitting there
looking all smug this is the first of
many shots of military personnel who
have access to classified information
watching the news to see what's
happening massive casualties in New York
offensive lines are being set up in
Boston so are there no massive
casualties in Boston then it's a coastal
city - if they're already that's good at
repelling the alien threat I'd rather be
watching a movie called battle Boston
although I'm sure they find some way to
set the finale in Fenway is the title of
this movie battle Los Angeles with a
colon or the way it's shown here which
makes me think the movie is asking me to
battle Los Angeles leading the use of
California love and the action movie
would cause Tupac to roll over in his
grave if he were actually dead I would
say only as old as it feels outside so
I'm worried about I can't feel a damn
thing because that mean this isn't an
idiom or a joke or turn a phrase
it's Nantz revealing an AJAX lie
community of pain what happened that
picture of us in Iraq with that camels I
mean your girlfriend
haha we are bonding you and I we make
insult of each other yes also that's
pretty racist I did my 20 I know when to
get out me another story about an almost
retired vet that's pulled into action on
his last days of work this movie should
just be called no Sin City for falling
down into hell or high water also seven
had to make some tough calls a mind
especially that last one we all wish
your men made it home there was a
scenario by which we didn't wish your
men made it home but that's a way
different movie with darker more
interesting exposition they got the rest
of them in a package deal but the
producers really only hired Aaron
Eckhart's chin but his movie Andy what
are you done in your balls tomorrow we
shop for cakes I don't care how close
these two dudes are what a Stavrou doing
shopping with Harris and his fiancee
this isn't like tagging along on a trip
to target they're shopping for wedding
flowers man this shot is so Peterburg I
thought for sure Peter Berg did this
movie but he didn't so why not choice of
director to emulate I've always wanted
to make movies like Peter Berg
yes girl is making a dude organizers
entire wedding two weeks before we
deploy movie thinks that if it gives
these short character introductions that
we're going to give to it's about them
once the battle los angeles starts
happening I'm sure this is a touching
moment but I'm too distracted by the way
they're shooting this like it's a voyeur
video to really care and now this guy
over here mr. LAN hey his mom's on so he
could join up to 17 thankfully
lance-corporal exposition is at this
party the guy just threw the rest of the
squadron hey did you like Independence
Day but wanted less interesting
characters in a super generic alien
Brett then if I got that movie for you
bringing it back to the company Mike I
need you they need one guy who just
basically retired
I know it's patriotic I think one man
can turn the tide in a war like this but
come on of course we know he's going to
make a difference because he's Aaron
Eckhart
but characters in this movie don't know
that sergeant Beck is being replaced by
Staff Sergeant Nantz later we find out
that Beck is on leave so I guess they
didn't need Beck on this mission even
though it's all hands on deck he's a
goddamn no-good gasps that's my grandpa
used to say pulling you up to squad
leader seriously I didn't get a bit
about these guys before but movie wants
me to keep up with these characters
promotions now we're being called in up
one evacuation center these meteors
assume so I realize that not every
officer is briefed on the details of the
mission shouldn't Martinez have some
idea about why he was called in the
central object are all the same
geometric state we appear mechanical in
nature they're almost like I don't know
battleships of some sort directed a year
later by holy Peter Burke how that
situation what I've been training for I
certainly hope so if they made you
lieutenant I hope it's not because
you've been training for fry cook at
McDonald's there are people in reporters
hanging out on a beach where a meteor is
about to hit the ocean
look I know people are stupid but this
malfunctioning camera is able to self
edit and get extreme close-ups of the
victims in this attack I know it's good
television but these are fucking Marines
you'd think they'd be standing there
with their dicks in their hands watching
TV they were just told to move out even
though all these soldiers are getting to
see an unfiltered look at the invasion
the movie decides to go with this wildly
cut found footage route cutting in
soldiers reactions and really when it
comes down to it making the movie a mess
and pissing me off
yaaaas PFC lenin was our second best
marksman just behind Lance Corporal
Guerrero um this information is
virtually worthless is there a scenario
by which you wouldn't have your first
and second best marksman on this mission
and if they weren't coming doesn't
somebody else become the first and
second best marksman in their place and
why would you lead your discussion with
the best marksman
I feel like this was just a worthless
way of saying we've got some guys or
greated shooting on this team
right already now Sergeant Nantz will be
taking over the staff side effects
because Staff Sergeant Beck is a piece
of dickless whore bitch is my kid
brother used to say in kindergarten you
got a Silver Star my brother came home
in a box feel like this is a very good
reason why Aaron Eckhart shouldn't be on
this particular team and Roll Creek
sorry it's been a long week I can
understand why a marine would be reading
the Bible before going into battle but
this Bible is hilariously over
diagrammed he has the word for in
parentheses has marked out most of the
pronouns for some reason and is
underlining random phrases
nyjah's wife if I die tell Staff
Sergeant Beck he's a hedonistic
douchebag piece of monkey spunk also I
love you and take care of the kid don't
marry anyone else and I guess they got
here too late for battle Orange County
director enjoyed the Bourne trilogy and
end of watch but felt like the
camerawork was a little too steady most
the Santa Monica has been clear to
sub-variants fucking what Santa Monica
has like ninety thousand residents not
including tourists and people who wanted
to look at the meteor shower they
cleared that down a couple hours just
gather survivors and your radio and
we'll have helicopters in the area to
evacuate you out why not send the
fucking helicopters right now you mean
you have to send a group of elite
fighters to Saving Private Ryan through
downtown Los Angeles instead of some
quick air support it must be a
metaphorical bomb drop for it to be in
quotes like this like really it's an
insult comic coming to the scene to spit
racial slurs at the aliens affiliate
harmonies branded behind the enemy live
all the car messenger are shaky and on
auto zoom please take precautions this
gritty Neel realistic alien invasion
movie is brought to you by Domino's
Domino's for when you gotta have it
delivered quick because you're about to
die these guys just walked out of a funk
in war zone it couldn't be more than a
quarter-mile away but just got real
quiet because we need some manufacturer
tension right now one thing is clear
the world is at war the radio is still
playing in this car even though it's not
running in the door is open and if the
battery's still working why isn't just
dead assholes head making a horn player
it's just a dog doc doc dog what's his
name huh Glen Marines take a break from
their incredibly dangerous and
time-sensitive mission to learn this
dog's name I'm sure it's a good dog but
if I were in this group that dog can go
to hell
you want calm man this movie's got a
long time without a jump scare cliche so
maybe I should take officer motherfucker
[Music]
everything these shots and this editing
represents these aliens were trained at
the finest stormtrooper school of aiming
guns
yelling aliens excitement and it's a
great thing that every interior room in
this movie has an expositional TV that's
not only working but has an excellent
cable connection hello how every single
shot of news in this movie also has to
show you how badly the Dow Jones is
doing during the middle of this alien
invasion
what night anybody got eyes on earth oh
no one of the thirty guys from the
squadron that we were introduced to a
few minutes ago not him washing machine
buzzes for no goddamn reason
well them to be a jump-scare unless
someone decided they needed to put a
wash in during the alien invasion look I
understand Lenihan is freaked out in the
wood but this is a trained soldier that
should never leave cover for a wide-open
space like this I guess the movie was
finally ready to show something aliens a
little alien is alone does that mean
that he's an alien or alone Ian help me
out here guys
scaring ball also say Leon had the
element of surprise at point-blank range
this point I wonder if the aliens are
actively trying to miss streets clear so
everyone's generally okay that they
survived a precision attack that
included an ambush from high ground
we're all back together with an UP
health and ammo to continue the mission
I mean simply but it's also kind of
Awesome you that's a us a tech sergeant
uh Lana Santos air force after Linda
Hamilton has her 50s all badass female
roles in Hollywood were automatically
assigned to Michelle Rodriguez okay vote
about 25 minutes first off can you be a
little more specific wouldn't want to
know the exact time left before the
rescue helicopter arrives also ten
minutes ago random arena before Yelp so
I'd synchronize those swatches if I were
you my spot whoa wait the optimal
signaling of the choppers to throw more
smoke out there what about like a flare
or something yeah the smokes blue but
it's already smokey around here right
the Marines consider the most
comfortable introduction to civilian is
to scream loudly while pointing a rifle
at them
it's an Emmanuel and everything will be
introduces Michelle Rodriguez Michael
Pena and Bridget Moynahan at the
40-minute mark these secondary
characters are played by actors so
famous there's a really good chance that
Tom Brady one of these people in his
lifetime officials are now saying any
civilian within 10 miles of the coast to
try to make their way to fulfill its
very Forward Operating Base book heirs
but Dow Jones is under five Alvin now
we're doomed that one our promise
legally so now they got leadership yep
we can definitely assume a clear chain
of alien command by the location of this
one alien butthole when you invade a
place for its resources you wipe out the
indigenous population those are the
rules of any colonization
luckily CNN was able to get doctormick
alien colonization on air in perfect
time for some global exposition we have
a situation
y'all need to follow me is there ever a
time when this type of dialogue is more
useful than just telling people what was
going on damn it
this movie had consensual promise but
now it's just burning out cliche after
cliche we need to know exactly where to
hit this thing maybe I can help I'm a
veterinarian
there's no frontal lobe no temporal lobe
no parietal lobe you can already tell
the alien doesn't have those things just
open this up five seconds ago right this
is our last shot hopefully all the
aliens you encounter will be half dead
and you can tear them open at will to
get to their hearts it's nice and I know
this because it's not making that Star
Wars podracer sound effect anymore
that's how we chill just to the right
where the heart would be Jesus how did
you figure that out so quickly how are
you supposed to aim right of the heart
when they all have that protection that
one dude shot the alien by the pool over
a hundred times and he apparently missed
that spot because they came back out of
the water like Jason the first Friday
the 13th movie I got three more you can
also explode the aliens to death so no
need to worry about their weak spot I
don't know how this bus is supposed to
drive through roads and avoid aliens
when we've seen all the roads are like
parking lots at this point ha
turn off that radio to tracking our
tables turn up okay fine the aliens are
tracking their signals but why haven't
they destroyed satellites carrying CNN
and of course HBO wouldn't this invasion
go down better without an informed
public or do the aliens think CNN is
fake news alien ship decides not to
destroy this bus because hey they might
need that later for parties
look it's ridiculously made that perfect
of a grenade throw but I'm really more
annoyed by how close these ships already
get to the gas pump with open flames on
their thrusters but they don't at night
man survives us only choice take the
freeway and be sure to keep it about 50
miles an hour for God's sake check off
in case you didn't know from the 17
other instances in this movie lieutenant
Martinez is the one in charge
despite Staff Sergeant Nantz having more
experience it's never been one conflict
surrounding this other than the brief
exchange at the beginning also why would
the freeway not also be completely
blocked this is mother Los Angeles
freeways packed at 3:00 a.m. on a
Tuesday but open during an alien
invasion well ain't this squadron a
temporal oddity 25 minutes away from
everything
lundi saves money by telling the
assistant director to go to any la
freeway you can think of right now to
get footage of burning cars it was kind
of the doomed la drivers to form a
decent path for this boss before they
died hang on I have a headed west
they were just in Santa Monica on 10th
Street so either they're headed straight
into the ocean which is the exact
opposite of safety or they're going to
the Santa Monica Airport which is only
west in opposite world hell are you
doing you guys need another gun way to
go Michelle Rodriguez I mean why would
there ever be a reason for somebody not
to be helping right now unless you're
that guy from hacksaw Richard are you
seeing bullets hitting the right side of
where the heart should be because I
don't
yeah we're winning no doubt that this is
some powerful weapon here but it looks
cumbersome you have to push this thing
down the street why isn't this a vehicle
this thing is more awkward than the
walkers and Empire Strikes Back how many
go
toad outside wonder girl honestly this
action scene has been cut to death so
much he could have said any number and
I'd have no choice but believe him
with all this going on I am reminded
that they needed to get out of the area
in 25 minutes and while only 6 minutes
have passed since then this battle has
really gone on for way longer and the
bomb should already be dropping unless
you're saying what we're watching is
real time which means you turn the tide
against an alien force in 6 minutes and
that simple seriously how is this any
different from shooting the alien by the
pool earlier you're telling me this guy
I missed but John cube civilian was able
to knock one out with a couple of
bullets and I know they know where to
shoot now it's basically no different
from what happened to the pool alien
that kept surviving all the bullets Oh
daddy is trying hard to make me care
about Nancy's backstory instead of
focusing on aliens blowing stuff this is
instead of water martini echo company
second Battalion fifth Marines ooh-rah
ok this movie doesn't look like a
typical alien invasion or war movie so I
had higher hopes than seeing a bland
generic cliche fest but it's totally
generic right down to the officer
sacrifices himself to kill the baddies
and save the unit cliche and since it
fooled my ass into thinking it might be
different I'm going to add 10 more sins
for the subterfuge the fact that Bridget
Moynahan character's name Michelle and
the idea that michelle monaghan could
have taken her place halfway through the
movie without me noticing is much more
entertaining than watching this movie
still half a click inside the bombing
zone can you believe that only took 10
minutes felt like more did it raw
did you just lead to lieutenant back
here to die you look that way even
though everyone's going to die and oh
probably 25 minutes or so Marines again
waste time speculating on Nancy's
backstory looting we're estimating with
26 17 countries are now in full attack
but our cable operations in these cities
remain remarkably intact I know we can't
believe it either
yeah we wipe it up we take out their
haiyan's have one main ship that
controls everything cliche aliens run
the same playbook as vampires kill the
head vampire they all died nobody in
this advanced alien race ever heard of
not putting your larvae all in one
basket hey that's your to drop yeah if
the bombs didn't drop at the immediate
moment to which you had your watch's
time then they aren't going to drop the
bombs I understand the military at least
tries to be precise but come on it could
be a minute or two late right
right one alternate extraction site is
still operational according to this map
that may not be accurate anymore due to
the passage of time mr. Rincon is dead
oh no it's sad that guy was so Michael
Pena
so much to see people who exhibit the
properties of Michel Pina die I got any
brain for the others because we range
don't luckily for the morale of the
squadron this emotional Michael Bay
asked mine along takes place at a time
when no Marines or otherwise marina you
getting us out to staff Sarge
or are we expended we interrupt this
alien invasion military movie to bring
you a very special episode of mash that
dead I'm here like a punchline some bad
joke is that the punchline to any joke
you have eleven passengers requesting
evacuation at alternate extraction point
Charlie the aliens were monitoring the
radio signals early in the movie but I
guess they got bored and stop listening
to these fools discuss the alternative
extraction point over the open airwaves
unless you ever see what I push back and
saying God you do huh yes that such a
fully loaded weaponized vehicle was left
behind on this SOB alien raid even
though they killed every motherfucker on
the base even aliens haven't evolved
enough to realize that they need to
shoot the goddamn tire strange but none
of the aliens have one of those Imperial
Walker things they have back at the
bridge seem to be fairly useful
technology that they forgot when they
set up the space got that nasty stuff
all over my mouth man buddy if you know
I'm doing any fire today Michael Vania
is dead let's get home and buy home I
mean some military base where we'll stay
temporarily until the aliens decide to
attack inlet
the taxes are just talking I and the
traffic is a nightmare the latter for
Martinez is why will you get it sooner I
thought after Martinez died I might have
a chance with her now I just want her to
know how I feel oh wait that's
Martinez's letter isn't it
there wasn't one bit of suspense to this
scene now the actions going into
hyperdrive and it's dark the editor has
film cuts all over his hands from all
the cutting is doing even though the
footage is probably digital the camera
operator drank 10 shots of Red Bull
cappuccino latte and the director stayed
home with an illness during the shooting
this scene also still isn't really part
of these alien quads game they've just
been blasting fools left and right but
here they're able to sneak up right on a
gang of highly trained military
personnel without a PA lien command
center conveniently pokes its head
outside over the street so the good guys
will be able to kill it easier I mean
seriously they went to the trouble of
putting this thing underground but left
a wide-open hole and couldn't even fit
the entire thing down there right over
this command asset which is completely
unguarded above ground also I really
don't know if they were in the sewers
long enough for night to become day you
don't know either and I bet you ten
dollars movie doesn't know right at
heart right right of the aw I'm pretty
sure you already knew that considering
you were there when Nan's made that
discovery I feel like this is a reminder
to the audience or it might have been a
note left in the margins by the
screenwriter to remind the director
about some day totally been glossing
over until now also this how to kill an
alien detail but seem super important of
the plot earlier hasn't been used once
until this moment all the aliens fire
their usual guns when we've seen them
use much better tech throughout the
movie they probably know it's the end so
they gave up on doing anything smarter
skillful you know what all the action in
this movie is the fitting of the
director who gave us the Texas Chainsaw
Massacre the beginning wrath of the
Titans and Earth's remake of Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles that's how these
assholes prematurely celebrate so much
they should work for NASA advanced alien
weapons somehow keep missing the easy
target with a pinga laser coming out of
it even though the missile was in the
area and the soldiers on the ground
notice it coming in and it took forever
to get that laser pointed at the alien
ship this missile still gets its target
killed my brother I mean now if you
sharlinda jaws anymore yeah but there
was a ton of those big soldiers on the
ground and I did plenty of them are
still around this area alone also they
only took out the one command center in
Los Angeles so I assume they'll have two
independent say the method of victory to
the other countries via Morse code me
dance is already using his pistol here
which should be hilariously incompetent
in this fight by the way but is shown
abandoning his rifle in the next shot
then going to the pistol realizing aaron
eckhart didn't look badly enough in the
last close up the makeup department went
with the dirt and blood bukkake look for
the flight back to base why now you
brought their shift
it's gone out to every army in every
city so they do will have to find the
command center and hope that a big piece
of it is hanging out in broad daylight
and that bombing it will cause the
command center to start flying out in
the open and then the soldiers in the
ground will also have to get very lucky
to point a laser just so I mean it's a
piece of cake really
[Music]
it was bad start
promise me you won't let me be taken
alive by some gossip reading from
another world bad but no promises in
combat you either die a hero or you live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain had to make some tough calls mi
do mainly you will have to be not
current you see across street hi I'm
show you in Wyoming get off get off
I saw this in a movie about a but that
had to speed around the city keeping its
speed over 50 I think it was called the
bus that couldn't slow down captain my
captain my captain
and g-force thank you
[Applause]
don't get no benefit we've been coming
to the same party for 12 years now and
in no way is that depressing
okay I was at a wine tasting with my
cousin mescal so mainly grades and you
know I don't live right now you know but
there was a Roseate I say today it was
delightful
you getting up top to staff sergeant or
are we expended well we some kind of
Suicide Squad